what's up dudes max here today I'm gonna
be showing you trunks and Dragonball
Fighters my personally most requested
and probably favorite Dragon Ball
character there is he's kind of a unique
one so let's take a look now trunks is a
character that excels in his normals he
has some very good long range normals as
well as the sword attack which is
reaches way further than it should in
all honesty and at the same time this
character is difficult to use because it
doesn't seem like some stuff combos with
them but it takes a little bit of
practice right now I think trunks is
sort of a mid-level character while many
of the other characters in the game take
a little bit less skill but at the same
time trunks has so much fun with them
now trunks is a character that has
several long range normals that are very
good essentially trunks gets in and
stays in with his variety of special
attacks and let's go over those specials
the first one is fireball forward with
any of the attack buttons you get this
sword strike that hits multiple times
and pushes the opponent away the medium
one goes a little bit farther and if you
want to use a little bit of meter on the
heavy one you can do multi hitting
strikes that do quite a bit of damage
what's interesting about this thing is
that you can only really combo into it
from this attack and it's kind of hard
to set up because you're in the air
trunks only has supers on the ground so
you got to find a way to get back to the
ground now this is where the character
excels in his approach he has this jump
attack which jumps forward and back when
you do fire ball back with light and
medium and from this attack you can do
any of your normals including the
fireball this means that at the end of
block strings trunks can go in at any
point and cross you up which is
extremely good now the thing with trunks
that is kind of difficult is getting
damaged but that's where this character
excels is that the beginning of a team
where he starts the combo but doesn't
exactly end it so you go in finish a
combo here and then bring in the next
character to finish right after and this
is in my opinion where trunks excels at
a character he is a lot of fun but he
takes a little bit of work mostly
because the other characters do a lot of
damage right now and I think that kind
of makes sense because trunks is going
to be a very very popular character and
he looks so cool and possibly has one of
the best level threes in the game let's
take a look
[Applause]
ouch that's all I got from the brief
time we've had with trunks and good luck
to anyone that's going to be using this
character he's a lot of fun when you get
used to him